we'll jump to the story from Fox News
this is Federman blast South Africa
genocide case against Israel amid unrest
crime sit this one out so the
interesting thing is he's maybe because
his brain is broken he said when you now
look at what's going on in South Africa
now they should sit this one out and
everyone immediately said in reference
to genocide is he talking about what's
going on with the farmers and of course
there are people who have come up like
no no he's talking about a part hide no
that's not even true I don't know what
he thought he was talking about but his
own statement now is he was talking
about Sudan apparently well I think
they're trying to cover up I think he
actually cuz's he said some pretty like
I said he's more based than a lot of the
Republican Senators right now I mean he
he was all for what was it us steel uh
he came out in favor of you can't get
rid of that you can't tell it I guess it
was the Japanese uh he came out he he's
been very pro-israel he's frankly
actually mocked a lot of the Palestinian
uh you know protesters that started
going into his office and around that
he's come out publicly as a Democrat
senator who a year ago it was pretty
darn woke said like of course we have to
shut down the Border what's going on
there is absolutely insane like of of
course you know so it it doesn't take a
leap based on the actions of even the
last few months to say he was probably
talking about the white genocide of
farmers which again you know if it's
happening to White farmers in South
Africa I guess that's fine according to
the mainstream media today but it's
actually happening and it's a real
problem and if we had actual journalists
rather than sort of Dei woke regime
propagandists you know they'd actually
be writing stories about it absolutely
it's it's fascinating to to see his kind
of development since the poor guy could
could barely speak sometimes it's almost
like the treatment process from the
brain aneurysm actually was like now
he's actually getting better and he's
not espousing the insane policies of the
left that might be the way how you deal
with the woke M virus but I I I I I'm I
find him fascinating ever since he he
came on the political stage I always
said I I want to see him as the VP for
Biden I I literally created bid Biden
fetman as a way to spur on this idea and
and the way that things are kind of
shaping up the way that he's being kind
of prompted up there it could happen but
now now the left is going after him
because he's saying things that you know
at at times make sense and again I'm a
guy that was I was crapped on by the
mainstream media over and over again
because like you know when he was
running that campaign and when he became
a I'm like he there were times he was
getting on a stage he forgets where he
is he couldn't form a complete sentence
and he but he'd keep going and it was
clearly like an episode and I I sort of
went after it and people called me an
ableist that's apparently someone who uh
discriminates against those with
disabilities and I was like well I I
just don't think it's an unreasonable
expectation even in this was 2023
America to expect a United States
Senator who's making trillion dollar
decisions Andor could be a deciding vote
in a 50-50 Senate to send our children
to war to be able to have basic
cognitive function yeah if he was a dude
at a restaurant at another table and you
check out guy at a place I love that
you're gainfully employed I think that's
awesome I'll give you a high five and
respect it like if you're making
trillion dollar decisions if you're
making life or death decisions we should
not be like how dare you discriminate
it's like it's it in no reasonable
Society in history now or in the future
would it not be okay to be like hey man
we we just need a a a reasonable level
of cognitive function to sit there I
feel like that with age it's not age
though cuz Biden and and Don are like
similar ages but like it it's mental
cogn cognitive sense and we got all
these old people and I don't want to be
agist I really don't cuz some people are
70 even 80 and they're brilliant
brilliant clear thinkers but there's
something too like we got to we got to
talk about these not everyone ages the
same but by the way listen you're not
allowed to talk about looks anymore but
it's the same thing you see people you
know I there's guys I'm 46 there's guys
I graduated college with I'm embarrassed
to tell people like we went to school
together cuz like I like I can't look
like that if I look like that you know
you age differently the same thing
happens with cognitive cin God willing
we all go there longer but I know guys
in their 60s that are a mess I know guys
in their 90s that would run circles
around the average 20 or 30 year old you
see it a lot in business like some of
these guys you know they peak in their
60s and 70s business-wise and later uh
you know because they've been able to
sort of learn and grow and get to a
point and then you see you know Joe
Biden I mean my father had a sort of an
interesting he he used to tell me the
story you know early but he was having
you know conversations like Ted Kennedy
back in the day like Joe Biden was
always known as the stupidest person in
the United States Senate like throughout
his entire tenure there that that that's
not like disputed that's just Senate
understanding now he's also had two
major brain aneurisms I wrote about this
in li My Book liberal privilege like
he's had things that if you asked you
know let's call it all the same teles
psychologist that said like if my father
grabbed a rail walking down a slippery
ramp he must be in the later stages of
cognitive decline if you ask those same
people honestly and they had even a
modum of intellectual honesty like no
one could go through two brain aneurisms
and and be 100% fine almost
statistically impossible well it depends
on which version of of Biden we're
talking about here as of course a lot of
people watch a video of him 10 years ago
watch a video of him even as EP it's
like it's a different voice it's a
different speed it's like say what you
want there's a decline it ain't the same
yeah I remember talking to him a couple
years ago specifically when he came to
Pakistani isi funding and meetings that
he had uh right before 2001 and uh he he
he was sharp he was quick he answered
right back he was taking questions from
people left and right this was just a
few years ago now the poor guy if it's
even him According to some people who
are saying hey there he's probably
replaced by some kind of other
impersonator uh that's also possible
possible too but but a lot of world
leaders have a lot of impersonators if
you're dealing with someone who can't
walk around or or can't hold their
bowels why wouldn't you use the
impersonator right I me yeah but it's
like Shane Gill right the Roomba sort of
analogy Shane Gill said and it's perfect
like he's on a stage like I don't know I
do a lot of public speaking I get up on
a stage I talk I walk off the way I
can't I mean he gets lost I got I got
like cancelled on social because I said
well he's clearly Lo no no no he was uh
shaking hands with someone in the AUD I
was like but the audience was there and
he's pointing 180 degrees from he was
clearly lost whatever they jacked him up
with to give the appearance of you know
even you know temporary Lucidity had
worn off and he's lost but it's not like
it happened once and you forgive it
happens every time you see him speak
there's a reason you know he had nothing
on the schedule today but his you know
wife was on ABC News talking about his
great level of energy he's taken 40% of
his time on vacation as president like
there comes a point in time you have to
call that's why they like he's
the puppet there's a video right now of
uh of trump senor walking out onto stage
for the town hall and he he walks up
stops looks to his left walks a little
bit looks at somebody and they're like
look he got lost and I was like I saw
this claim first a tweet saying Donald
Trump getting lost on the stage says so
much and I was like oh he got lost I was
like I'd like to see this and then I
watched the video I'm like where in this
video does he get lost yeah he made eye
contact with someone was like hey how
you doing right and then he starts
walking Jo doing like an air handshake
to the curtain for seven or eight
seconds remember when he started
speaking to the in backwards so he was
on stage and he was looking at the
curtains talking and everyone's like
well how many times have we seen the
headline he walked off the stage before
the ceremony was finished like he was
you know doing something and giving a
ceremony and he shakes hands and then
just walks away through the middle of
the crowd and they're like no over here
how many times have we seen the video of
him you know trying to be guided into
the Oval Office by the Secret Service
because he walks past the entrance of
the office he's occupied for the last
three years I have one word one
word TR in that sh of of pressure yo
this is like this is something where
people make the mistake of of comparing
one president to another president it
has nothing to do with Donald Trump that
dude is sharp his mind is healthy and
clear Biden and fedman we can talk about
in in a little bubble if we want to what
do we do when our Representatives get
messed up in the head you're supposed to
do something about it but they don't
they they won't because the reality is
this the Democrats listen I honestly
whoever is actually in charge of the
Biden admin whether it's Susan Rice or
the Obamas or whatever he's the perfect
Fall Guy cuz he's actually doing all the
things Obama would have loved to have
done open borders pushing the trans crap
you gender surgeries for three-year-olds
that can't make other decisions in their
life but sure you can make that
life-altering decision because they they
wouldn't be willing to destroy their
reputation they wouldn't put that face
in front of the American public they're
happy to throw him under the bus because
he'll sign in you know like he's like
Ron Burgundy put it on the telepromter
he'll say it and it's the gospel he'll
sign it if if you're sticking in front
of him but they could have him do
anything in terms of foreign policy and
War and always just use him as a
scapegoat ex 100% he's just the he's the
Fall Guy so the he's actually for the
radical Democrat agenda been quite
effective because they can actually do
the things that the American public
wouldn't let them get away with do you
think it's Democrat because I think of
it as like a global monetary but I I
sort of look at the Democrat and a lot
of that sort of world economic Forum
globalist you know those ideologies are
sort of the they're not one in the same
but they're blending significantly and
the's uh uh uh view on this is Nicki
Haley is their Inside Job strategy if
they can't defeat Donald Trump at the
polls in the general they'll try and
beat him in the primary with Nikki
Hillary yeah well that that's why I said
when there were people like oh Nikki
Haley should be VP I was like can you
imagine the I don't know if I can curse
the stage in the game but the curing
yeah gu the merey that would be going on
from her team trying to subvert
everything that he did from every moment
like it's like so I don't you know it C
someone put out there food test yeah the
CIA would get their heart attack gun out
right away and then they would inst yeah
with the or people people joke like hey
Don you should run this VP because then
no one's assassinating your father I go
that's wait a second like because uh you
know but yeah I mean that it would be a
disaster so yeah there's no question
there's plenty of and by the way like I
said we're talking about you know half
of the Republic the United States Senate
I mean they're not all that different
from the Democrats Nikki Haley is you
know Hillary Clinton uh dressed up as a
conservative for Halloween like it give
me a break like he wants to be in every
war imaginable stoo a big corporate like
it's it's lunacy at this point thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at
timcast.net
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next
time